when you first start looking through a
microscope at microorganisms it's very
obvious that each little cell is its own
thing but then as time goes on and you
start to understand their relationships
and their dependence on each other and
also everything's dependence on them
each microbe starts to feel like a piece
of some much broader even global
organism and of course species of all
kinds and sizes have their ecological
impacts and this actually becomes much
more obvious when you make that
ecosystem less global by say putting it
in a little box then you might have seen
one of these boxes recently maybe in
your home or at a restaurant or the
doctor's office we're talking of course
about aquariums this tank is just one of
those tanks at a mall aquarium store
it's got some reefs and some fishes
swimming around living in full display
for people passing by but just give it a
moment just a few seconds and there that
is the disembodied hand of an aquarium
shop worker who probably went to work
expecting the usual aquarium shop
business until James our master of
microscopes came in and asked if he
could please have some water from the
tank science is always a team effort
and fortunately this shop worker was a
willing collaborator searching around
for biofilm and other bits from the tank
in response to various requests thrown
his way of course there are plenty of
macroscopic animals in the aquarium to
admire have you ever wanted to see what
a starfish looks like when you're up
really close yeah I mean of course you
have but the real focus of this
expedition wasn't the fishes or the
large invertebrates that we can clearly
see with our own eyes
what we want to see is what else is in
that tank this question is actually
pretty important for any aquarium you
might want to set up at home sure you
might be most excited about the fish but
fish waste is full of ammonia which can
accumulate to toxic levels if left
unchecked in nature microbes play an
essential role in the nitrogen cycle
including taking extremely stable
atmospheric nitrogen and turning it into
nutrients like these tricho des Miam do
or by consuming nitrogenous waste to
make sure that aquatic ecosystems have
the same cleaning abilities built-in
people install biofilters that contain
nitrogen consuming bacteria in their
aquariums it's sort of like building
wastewater treatment into the artificial
ecological neighborhood and beyond the
basic care of keeping tanks scientists
have been studying the microbial
composition of aquariums to explore all
sorts of questions
one group collected tank water from
seven Rhode Island pet shops to examine
the diversity of microbial communities
between them finding potential sources
of pathogens that might require further
study another group observed that
freshwater aquarium biofilters are
dominated more by ammonia oxidizing
archaea than they are by bacteria there
are of course also large aquariums like
very large so large you have to drive
out to visit them so you can stand in
awe and yes scientists have been
studying the micro biomes of these large
tanks too this includes a study of the
ocean Voyager exhibit in Georgia one of
the largest aquariums in the United
States where 14 months of tracking the
microbial community of the exhibit
revealed a surprising dynamic and
changing community despite the relative
stability of the water itself just for
reference the ocean Voyager exhibit
contains about 6.3 million gallons of
artificial seawater and it houses very
cool odd animals including the black tip
reef shark the long comb saw fish and
the porcupine ray in contrast the Moloch
where iam has a lot less water in it and
the fish are not quite as varied but
fortunately we don't need millions of
gallons of water to find fascinating
ecological diversity we just need a
microscope so we were pretty impatient
to see what was in that carefully
obtained mall tank water one of the
first organisms that caught our
attention was foraminifera this kind of
conch-shell looking thing for the Nefera
or forums for short our protists and
they can be found living all over the
ocean both in terms of depth and
geographical location there are around
4,000 species of forums around the world
of which we found only a handful in this
sample their shelves come in different
shapes and are made up of different
material depending on what species they
are now forums may look innocuous but
they've been around for over 500 million
years and with all those forums living
and dying over that long period their
shells have built up on the deep ocean
floor accumulating to the point where in
death they are practically a geological
entity and turn the chemical composition
of their shells has helped us better
understand how our oceans and climate
have changed over millions of years
[Music]
but while we're watching our new forum
friends something else came along you
can see it here that long thin line
snaking between the magnified sand
grains it looks like a worm but we think
it's actually a track Alaura fish and I
do not know if we're pronouncing that
correctly
a mysterious single-celled organism it's
difficult to find a lot of information
on truckle orifice probably because it's
been difficult to culture in the lab for
further study even filming it turned out
to be a challenge the slide we were
watching it on had too much sand and
debris in it for us to get a good
recording so we tried moving it over to
a new slide taking off the coverslip and
using a micropipette to grab it except
that once we removed the coverslip that
little guy just disappeared it took
three hours to find it and prepare it in
this sample but it was worth it for this
close-up view of just how weird this
unicellular organism is what else did we
find on amoeba spreading against
microbial fauna as its own internal
crystals Sparkle like an opening and
tree branches that give way to a galaxy
there are also long cyanobacteria stalks
the idling dinoflagellates the stunning
trick o Dez Miam filaments and this
ciliate who seemed to not quite know
what it wanted to be doing I know that
feel buddy
and all of this from some scoops taken
from a mall aquarium all of these
organisms make those clear boxes of
glass not just a storage tank for some
pretty fish but a living ecosystem with
millions of organisms all depending on
each other to turn the basics of
chemistry into the majesty of life
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and if you like this
show who you really want to thank are
these people whose names are on the
screen right now our patrons on patreon
who make it possible for us to search
through grains of sand for hours so that
we can get a good picture of a weird
microbe thank you for indulging with us
and allowing us to indulge in this
curiosity if you want to see more from
our master of microscopes James check
out Jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us you can
find us at youtube.com slash micro
cosmos